- [Voiceover] Let's say that this is me
in this column over here,
and that this is you in
that column over there.
And let's say that you are in possession
of a nice juicy, of a nice
juicy apple right over here.
Let me draw this apple properly,
let me make the leaf in green.
So you are in possession of this apple,
and I'm hungry, I would
like to have an apple.
And I just assume while
you posses this apple,
I assume that you own it,
so I go up to you and say,
"Hey, can I buy this apple from you?"
And you say, "Okay, yeah.
I don't really need it,
"I'll sell it to you for a dollar."
And so I give you a dollar,
I give you one dollar, and
then you give me the apple.
Then you give me the
apple, so now I have it,
so now I have the apple.
Somehow the apple got smooshed
a little bit in the transaction.
So now I have, I have,
now I have the apple.
Now when I did that transaction,
there were some
assumptions that were made,
I assumed that possession of the apple
was equivalent to ownership of the apple.
I assumed, whoops, I assumed possession
is equal to ownership.
And you might be thinking, "Wait, wait,
"under what cases would possession
"not be equal to ownership?"
Well what if you just picked this apple
from your neighbors garden?
The rightful owner of that
apple is your neighbor,
but you just picked it,
maybe you swiped this
from the corner store.
Maybe you found this on a bench
and you said, "Okay, well it doesn't seem
"anyone else is claiming it.
"So I'm just going to claim this apple."
But maybe someone else
had left it on the bench,
and then they come back an hour later,
said, "What happened to my apple?
"I'm the owner of that apple."
So you see that even in
the case of an apple,
possession might not
be equal to ownership.
So these two things
might not be equivalent.
But for something as small as an apple as,
I guess you could say financially
not as important,
something that's you know
has a market value of a dollar.
It might be too much trouble to kind of
do a background check on the apple
to see do a forensic analysis to see
who is guarding the apple came from
or to see is someone else had legal right,
legal title to the apple.
And so for things like apples,
we tend to just transact just assuming
that possession equals ownership.
Now let's take, let's up
the stakes a little bit.
Instead of an apple, let's say we're
talking about a house.
So let's say that you are in possession
of this nice yellow house.
So let me draw, we
definitely want to visualize
what a nice yellow house would look like.
It's got some windows here,
so and there's some nice gardening.
There's, so you, you are in possession
of this nice house.
So what does possession
of the house means?
Well, it means you're living in it,
you have the keys to the house,
your station wagon is in the driveway.
Your stuff is in the
closet, your furniture.
You have pictures of you
and your family on the wall.
So you seem to be in
possession of this house.
And you stick a for sale sign out on.
So, for sale.
So you put a for sale sign
outside of this house,
and I'm new to town, and I need a place
for me and my family to live.
And so I say, "Hey, you know,
"I'd like to buy that house.
"How much is it?"
And you say, "It's $100,000."
You say, "Okay, it seems like a reasonably
"good deal compared to other houses
"in this neighborhood.
"I want to buy it."
And you say, "Great."
So I walk up to you, I write a check
for maybe I even have cash for a $100,000.
So a little bit more serious transaction
than the apple transaction.
And then in exchange you give me
the keys to the house.
So now I have the keys to the house.
I'll draw some keys here.
So keys to the house.
And you say, "Give me an hour."
And you pack up all of your stuff,
take your pictures off the wall,
put them in your station
wagon, and you leave.
And you say, "Okay well, I guess I'm just
"going to move in to the house."
Now, you probably are thinking,
"Something is suspicious here.
"Something is, makes us feel
a little less comfortable
"doing this transaction than this
"transaction over here."
Because this house,
just because the person
happen to be in it and had the keys to it,
didn't mean that they owned the house.
So once again, possession
does not necessarily
equal ownership.
We can think of a lot
of scenarios for a house
where possession does not equal ownership.
They might have been renting the house,
they might have been renting.
They might have been guest in the house.
And maybe the owners, the real owners
were off to work and their
faces were in the pictures
just because they were
the owner's brother-in-law
or something.
So maybe they were guest in the house.
Maybe they were,
maybe they just saw a vacant house,
maybe this is someone
else's vacation house,
and said, "Hey you know what,
"I know these people don't show up
"during the summer, so
I'm just going to go there
"change the locks, have the keys,
"and I'm going to pretend
like I live there.
"And then I'm going to
try and find somebody
"new to town and I'm going
to sell them the house
"for a $100,000."
And if you think all of these things
are kind of crazy scenarios,
they've all happened.
Because as you can imagine
there's some people for whom who have
who are I guess a little
bit less scrupulous,
who's ethics are questionable,
who could be very tempted by this.
So you could imagine for,
when you're talking about
big dollar figures, people have tried
some fairly major scams.
So how do you, and you
know, and once again,
just in the case of the apple,
maybe someone left it on the bench,
and someone thought that it was their,
you know you thought it was your apple
now that you found it.
There could be, it doesn't
have to be just scamming,
it could be, I thought
I inherited this house,
but then some other relatives shows up,
who is closer to the
previous owner of the house,
and said, "No, no, wait, wait, wait.
"You can give that
house to the son-in-law.
"I am his younger brother or
I am his long lost child."
Or whatever else it might be.
So you might have thought
that you own the house,
but there might have been
some other claim on it.
And maybe you bought the house out right
or you thought you bought it,
but maybe the previous owner had you know
was in a dispute with their
brother or their sister
over the house.
So there could be other claims on it.
And so the way that, the
way in modern society
is that we deal with this,
where we see who has ownership rights
or another ways of thinking about it,
who has title?
So this is an important word.
Who has title?
Or I guess you could say proof of title.
When I talk about title,
this is ownership rights,
we're talking about real,
right to live in the house,
it's a right to do what you, you know,
garden around the house,
has the right to modify the house.
So the question of who has
title or evidence of title,
evidence of title, happens
through legal documents.
Evidence of title.
And these legal documents
are called deeds.
So let me write them.
So the legal type.
These legal documents are called deeds.
And deeds, so when I,
so if I wanted to buy
this house from you,
you would, we would get an attorney,
and then we would draft
a deed that transfers,
that transfers the
property from you to me.
But you're saying, "Wait, wait, wait,
"that still doesn't you know prove to me
"that the house is all good."
And then that's why I would
do a title search on it.
So there's actually companies
that do title searches,
and they're going to go
to the public records,
to the city or county records,
and they're going to
see, "Hey, what are all
"the deeds that have been
filed with the city?"
And whenever there's a deed,
if things have done properly,
it needs to be made of public record,
it needs to be filed
with the city or county.
And so when you do a title search.
So when you do, let's
do in a different color.
When you do a title search,
whoever is doing the title search
will look at the public records,
and they'll look at
all the previous deeds.
They'll look at the deed
that from the previous owner
of the house to you,
they'll look at the deed
from the previous owner even before that,
and they'll make sure that all of the
the titles, the title
transfer has been cleaned,
that there hasn't been any
weird claims on the house,
that there haven't been
liens on the house.
We'll talk more about what a lien is.
A lien is essentially
a claim on the house,
maybe three owners ago someone didn't pay
property taxes, and the
city is still saying,
"Hey, whoever owns this
house, owns us a $1000."
Maybe four owners ago there was someone
who did an improvement to the house,
and said, "Hey, that owner never paid me
"for the new driveway.
"I have a lien on this house.
"Whoever is benefiting from this driveway,
"who owns this house,
they still own me money
"before I were to remove that lien."
So the way that we do it
in a modern society is,
Okay, you say you're selling this house,
but before I actually give you the money,
I'm going to do a title search,
I'm going to make sure that there aren't
any other claims, I want to make sure
that you are the real
owner of the property.
And only then will money be transferred.